so on trends we released this on Tuesday
two things we're interesting that our
guys found more Steph and our guys so
men and women found which we only have
two people so uh so your guy and gal
found that two things I'm like thinking
about all of it first everyone talks
about meditation being like the most
popular like being a huge trend right
now people searching for sleep is
actually significantly more likes like
sleep products and not and this it makes
total sense because calm well I'm a
subscriber to calm the stories they're
pushing sleep like crazy yeah sleep
stories I think was the breakout product
for the breakout feature for that's
crazy
and so I didn't realize this until they
like point it out and I'm like oh yeah
that does make sense
sleep is way bigger than meditation and
meditation is huge sleep is also a lot
of people search for it because so for
meditation you're trying to teach a new
habit sleep everybody does also for
sleep a lot of you'll have problem
sleeping so they will actively search
for and pay for solutions that will help
them sleep I pay for a bunch of them I
pay for what's your sleep an Alexa app
called the nature sounds and they have
like 26 sounds and I pay extra money to
combine them it's all my the one I sleep
two is winter railroad and so what is
that sound like it's it's a train going
through the mountains of winter what's
the winter part what is the sound of
winter you hear like wid I love it you
shared something very personal there I
loved it I like sup played nature sounds
or sometimes I do ship in winter because
it sounds like an ice breaker and then I
like to turn off in 20 minutes no this
is also like one of these you know
hackathon projects or some developers
like okay watch this just say two words
and I go search the internet for sounds
and I smash them together and it makes
an audio thing yeah like for cons next
hackathon they should build this like I
don't even know what it could be like
chickens in China Street
[Laughter]
whatever says Sarah she doesn't like
that she liked to sit down with it she's
down with it so did you take any sleep
aids like part like like a vitamin or
supplement or CBD or something melatonin
melatonin yeah that work helper yeah it
does
if I really can't sleep I'll take one of
those units my computer died I think
that one of my unit
you know gel is that what it's called
units off it's a it's basically like a
mild dosage of nyquil without the
medicine part oh that's good so okay so
it's the way some people take nyquil
just to sleep and so this is the just
asleep part it's just I don't have a
cough yeah just a light version you
don't take that stuff I heard this
phrase today I could sleep in a ditch so
I just when I would decide to go to
sleep I instantly fall asleep and I do
not wake up at night ever
and so I'm blessed you know I am
typically like that as well but not as
bad there's this guy that we should
profile he he he's a Japanese
billionaire or sorry Chinese billionaire
and he started a so he's a he's a big
shot now and he owns like half a bank
and all his other [__] and he got rich
by creating a melatonin
he just took melatonin and reprinted it
and made it sexy and called it a sleep
aid and whatever it got huge and then he
launched the zynga of China and he ended
up buying like the building that they
lived in just like Zynga and or they
worked it and it became this huge thing
we'll have to do off to bring him up cuz
I love him because he's reckless and
he's built a fortune and lost it all
like three times right yeah you love
that I love those guys
okay and then we also talked about a Do
It Yourself perfume so apparently that's
a huge community is Do It Yourself
perfume and there's not a ton of
companies in the space so what's that
what's happening what are these people
trying to do they okay you don't want to
buy perfume they want to mix their own
at home yeah so basically perfume is a
huge business Paris Hilton a lot of
people forget about her she has sold
roughly five billion dollars of her
perfume cycling back to the porn
conversation earlier okay Paris Hilton
yes yes and let's say her stuff cost
$100 which it doesn't and it's typically
ninety percent margin yeah
incredible so huge fat margins and
everyone now knows us and so the idea
here is that people are trying to make
their own perfume at home and it's got
there's a lot of sub sub reddits around
it a lot of communities who discuss
different perfume like how to create
your own perfume but there aren't too
many companies that are making it easy
to make your own perfume and formulas
and things like that do that makes a lot
of sense this is like one of those
industries where when you hear about the
winner later you're like oh okay was set
up for success too for example a Warby
Parker you know one of the reasons
warburg Parker worked so well was that
the existing eyewear eyeglass you know
industry was all owned by this one
conglomerate that had price pricing
power and was marking [__] up like crazy
so they didn't have to like invent
something to lower the price they just
had to not be greedy and be like okay we
can offer this at a fair price and still
have margin and so and so you own
Cologne I own Cologne and so what you're
saying is basically cologne vastly
marked up in the same way razors are
super marked up and Dollar Shave Club
came in but instead of somebody just
making a Dollar Shave Club version of
Cologne
they're giving you a DIY kit and there's
like probably reddit communities of home
brewers for perfume yeah it's actually
pretty great and there's an infinite
number of recipes and scents so you're
gonna and what we're gonna try a bunch
is if you took it a step further an
interesting sense could be sold already
yeah so you could create a marketplace
where you could sell your yeah you to
just even to your own friends family you
could create a kit for people to do this
and make a better kit sure there's one
that exists another idea you know we
were talking about kids stuff earlier
like my niece would love to mix her own
perfume she would that would be like a
great afternoon and my my sister would
buy her you know this little
kid-friendly
perfume making kit and it's like one of
the arts and crafts things that she gets
to do and she makes it an Emeril who
comes over she gets to show him show her
show them there yeah I think you could
do this for kids and me a big deal
here's another angle that we found in
trends is soap do-it-yourself soap big
thing people want to make their own soap
and what was the third one juice but we
already know that's right juicing yeah
yeah my pretty great I like that
would have never known about that that's
pretty fascinating to me in fact I'm
gonna tell my sister to start this
business with the DIY perfume for kids
[Music]